I have very strong feelings about a
future in which robots become the kind
of conversational agent that pretend to
have emotional lives
shortly after I finished reclaiming
conversation I was interviewed for an
article in The New York Times about
hello Barbie so hello Barbie comes out
of the box and says you know and now I'm
just paraphrasing the gist
hi I'm hello Barbie I have a sister you
have a sister hey I kind of hate my
sister I'm jealous of your sister
do you hate your sister I just want
let's talk about how we feel about our
sisters it was it it just kind of know
stuff about you and is ready to talk
about the arc of a human life and
sibling rivalry and as though it had a
life a mother the feelings of jealousy
about a sister and was ready to relate
to you on that basis and it doesn't it's
teaching pretend empathy it's asking you
to relate to an object that has pretend
empathy and this is really not a in my
view this is really a not good direction
for AI to go there are so many wonderful
things for robots to do so many
wonderful things for robots to do having
pretend empathy having pretend
conversations about caring and love and
things that a robot can't feel about
their bodies and about their live isn't
about their mother isn't about their
sisters gets children and gets elders
which is the other target group for
these robots into a kind of fantasy
miasma that the
that that is not good for anybody
children don't need to learn pretend
empathy they need to learn real empathy
which they get from having real
conversations with real people who do
have sisters who do have mothers and I
think this is a very dangerous indeed
very toxic direction we worry so much
about whether we can get people to talk
to robots you know can you get a child
to talk to this hello Barbie can you get
an elderly person to talk to a sociable
robot what about who's listening there's
nobody listening
these robots don't know how to listen
and understand what you're saying I know
how to respond they they're programmed
to make something of what you say and
respond but they don't know what it
means if you say you know my sister
makes me feel depressed because she's
more beautiful than I am and I feel
my mother loves her more that robot
really does not do anything useful to
you with that information there's no
that that's not empathy and it's and
children need to know that they're being
heard by a human being that can do this
empathy game with them this empathy
dance with them so in the middle of a
time when we're having this crisis and
empathy to imagine that now we're going
to throw in some robots that will do
some pretend empathy I have to say that
and all the optimism of my book this is
the pessimistic part and I really end
the book with a kind of call to arms I
call it what did we forget when we think
when we talk to machines and I I mean it
to be a literally a call to arms that
this is not a good direction we don't
need to take this direction we just need
to not buy these products you know this
doesn't take a social revolution this
just takes consumer saying that they are
not going to buy these products and not
bring them into their homes